the movie 8 m 10 years before I even met
Eminem I had this curiosity conversation
with old dirty bastard of the wuang clan
I learned about the language of hip-hop
on the East Coast why it was there what
it was what it represented it
represented the inner voice of the
street and what was going to become the
language of the youth and all of a
sudden I start to think Hip Hop is not a
subculture it is the it's the culture I
meet Eminem and I realized that within
his story is overcoming shame wow I
could relate to that because I too had
to overcome a lot of shame we all have
some shame did it stop you from
something and it stopped him from being
able to look at an audience and show his
talent that was really what the movie
was about overcoming your injuries
getting over those berries so you can
actually express your talent